absolutely everything you think about
yourself and the universe could be an
illusion as far as you know you are real
and exist in a universe that was born 14
billion years ago and that gave rise to
galaxies Stars the Earth and finally you
except maybe not
you may actually not exist for real but
be the dream of a dead Universe you and
everything you think exists crazy as it
sounds this may be an unavoidable
consequence of our best scientific
theories about the universe okay this is
a bit much let's start at the beginning
we need to understand three concepts for
this idea to make sense
one the arrow of time
what distinguishes the past from the
future put a drop of red ink into a
glass of water and you see the ink
spread until it fills the container but
never the opposite colored water where
ink spontaneously concentrates and
becomes a drop at the surface again
time always seems to flow in the
direction in which the ink spreads but
if you take a microscope all you will
see will be a swarm of molecules
colliding at random there are no rules
no forwards and backwards every
individual motion that happens can occur
in Reverse but we perceive a sort of
Arrow of time that makes things happen
in One Direction how does this
phenomenon occur
well this Arrow of time is not actually
fundamental but a matter of probability
when Inca molecules spread to fill a
glass there are many different Slots of
space they can occupy and therefore many
different possibilities to combine them
and just like your chances of winning
the lottery grow the more tickets you
have the probability that ink molecules
will end up filling the glass is much
higher than the probability that they'll
concentrate in just one spot so it's not
that the ink forming a drop again is
forbidden by the laws of physics it's
just extremely unlikely to see it you'd
have to wait about 10 to the power of
106 billion years a one followed by 106
Dillion zeros if you had this much time
to spare eventually by pure random
chance you'd see a red blob form again
actually with enough time you could see
any shape forming like for example a
small red soggy brain okay let's move on
to idea 2.
2. the far future of the universe
our universe was born 14 billion years
ago in the Big Bang it expanded and
evolved to give rise to the myriads of
galaxies and things in other words the
universe is kind of a glass of water
with a lot of ink doing stuff it has an
arrow of time that the universe is not a
static class it seems to be getting
bigger at an ever increasing speed
because of dark energy basically
everything in it is getting more and
more diluted in about 100 trillion years
the last star will die then a few
interesting things will happen for the
next few decillions vantilians and
Googles of years eventually the universe
will be a dark place fully dominated by
dark energy a rapidly expanding ball of
pure space almost devoid of matter you
might think that this would lead to the
ultimate death of everything but dark
energy has one last surprise for you
inner Universe dominated by dark energy
space expands so dramatically that it
creates a cosmic Horizon around you a
border Beyond which nothing will ever be
able to reach you not even light so for
every practical purpose the universe has
become a glass of finite size about 36
billion light years wide surrounded by
an impassable Cosmic Horizon such a
universe glass is basically a giant
black hole turned inside out
we know that due to Quantum effects all
black holes emit a tiny amount of
particles a phenomenon known as Hawking
radiation and so does our inside out
black hole in the end this radiation
will fill the universe glass with
particles again at this point so far in
the future they're giving you a number
has no more meaning we've reached the
true final State the universe has now
become a closed box full of particles at
an extremely low but finite temperature
and since they have a temperature they
undergo random motions or in other words
a glass filled with water and ink and an
infinite amount of time ahead things are
about to become interesting again
three typing monkeys and fake universes
eternity is a long long time so now even
the most extremely unlikely things can
happen
the fluctuating particles are bumping
into each other over and over and over
again creating every combination of
particles that's possible
they're like a monkey typing at random
on a typewriter almost all of the time
it types gibberish but with enough time
eventually it will write the first acts
of Hamlet and with even more time the
complete works of Eminem
if ink in our universe glass generates
any random Arrangements of particles
what could they be well a spontaneous
fluctuation could give rise to a planet
or to a Galaxy or even to a lot of them
so maybe our universe has already ended
and all we see around us is a pop-up
Universe not a universe that evolved
from a big bang but one that fluctuated
into existence by pure chance and that
like the drop of ink will only exist for
a while before dissolving again
being random pop-up universes could be
similar to ours but with funny glitches
in some of these universes dinosaurs are
riding snails in another stars are made
of blueberries in another you're wearing
a funny hat
scientists in such universities wouldn't
understand those glitches so maybe the
greatest mysteries of physics are just
nonsense bugs of our pop-up universe but
not all possible fluctuations of our
dead Universe have the same probability
of occurring smaller fluctuations are
much more probable than bigger ones a
planet is more likely than a Galaxy but
you know what's even way more likely a
human brain
are you actually just a brain
you think therefore you exist but what
else do you truly know in the end your
brain is just interpreting signals from
your senses and creating a world that
you experience so technically you could
be just your brain that thinks the world
is real and if we follow the logic of
the ink in the universe class in
particular you could be a disembodied
brain that just by chance emerged in a
dead Universe with your complete set of
knowledge and memories this is a pretty
bizarre idea but if we do the maths it's
kind of pretty solid let's compare the
number of brains inside bodies in a
living Universe with a number of naked
brains in a dead Universe let's go
really big and imagine that a total of
100 quadrillion humans will live around
Earth and that the same amount of people
will live around every star in the
universe if we add this together we get
about 10 to the power of 41 brains
inside bodies that will exist
however in a dead universe that has had
enough time to explore all possible
fluctuations and that will exist forever
the number of naked brains that would
emerge is well infinite so the
probability that you're a floating brain
is not only vastly larger than the
probability that you're a real human
it's so inconceivably larger that we
can't even meaningfully quantify the
difference how do you compare a number
to Infinity so are you a floating brain
that exists for One Moment In Time then
basically forever passes and then you
exist for another moment in time maybe
not even in that order maybe your life
happens backwards and you just don't
notice maybe you've lived trillions of
times already
are you the dream of a dead universe
really like ready
wow probably not
first of all there are a few loopholes
for example Dark Energy could behave
completely differently from what we
think today and lead us to another
future or maybe our dead universe will
be too motionless to allow the creation
of brains even with infinite time or
maybe the universe will end up dying in
another way our understanding of the
cosmos doesn't have a solid enough
foundation for anyone to worry if
they're real or not loopholes aside if
you were a fluctuating brain all the
laws of physics stored in your brain
would have originated at random and
shouldn't bear any relation to the real
world
but we just used those laws to prove
that you're a floating brain so even if
you believe that you are a floating
brain you'd have to admit that you have
no good reason to believe that you are
actually a floating brain
okay so this hallucinatory trip might
teach us something about our theories
about the universe but in the end it's
just a really weird exercise in what you
can do with physics an exercise of what
brains and bodies are able to think
about so don't worry you're not a dream
of the Dead Universe probably
at koskazard we love discussing topics
like Portsmouth brains because we're
convinced that taking science and
philosophy seriously is really important
for having a positive impact on the
world we're lucky because this is our
job doing something impactful we also
enjoy if you're also aiming to make a
positive difference where should you
start well we've noticed a lot of advice
about having a positive impact isn't
based on the best available evidence
today's sponsor 80 000 hours aims to
offer some that is eighty thousand hours
is a non-profit career advice
organization that wants to help people
find fulfilling careers that also do a
lot of good in the world and their
advice is free to read online without
any hidden cast or fee later on they've
spent the last decade compiling and
conducting Research into topics like how
much impact can one person actually have
and what are the best ways to make a
positive difference on important Global
issues and like us they care a lot about
making sure their work is based on the
best available evidence and consultation
with experts you can read them main
takeaways and actionable advice in their
free online career guide that's recently
got a massive update for 2023 if you'd
like to read it for yourself and start
working towards a career that's both
meaningful and helps solve one of the
world's most pressing problems then you
can find it all completely free at
eighty thousand hours dot org slash
kotzgzart
wait
[Music]